you are so cute and pretty don't worry
it's just girls helping girls don't
worry about it just a little deodorant
you look so pretty where did you have
your dress from starting to show I miss
it order okay so I'm a little I'm a
little mad and let me tell you why
yeah ready to say hi to us yes boys to
girls only but boys will come to me a
question for him
we don't bite oh here bourbon here we
got you we got you hi oh my god we're
just so excited Lauren we haven't like a
little a little tip for you and you
promised me that I we got the exclusive
on YouTube right here on the carpet here
we are and now these people next to us
got the exclusive this morning on their
website and I don't know who gave it to
them it wasn't made because I kept the
secret and they told everyone I was like
I was secret now I'm like that idiot who
doesn't have a secret so how did that
happen you know what I don't know we
just show up in an award show we put up
put it out into the universe and
congratulations on your blossoming
relationship
yeah how did you guys meet because the
last time also we spoke before that
always hidden care off for information
for information and you said I was just
a music video we're friends he's such a
great guy and here you are like in love
so how does that happen more than
fashion known each other for oh wow at
least for a couple years and kind of
just kept in touch and then here
recently started hanging out a little
bit more and realized we enjoy each
other I will say this about her not only
is she beautiful but she's got the best
personality I've ever met it's so true
we can attest to it I agree
we're so happy for you guys and honestly
like I'm so happy for you I just love
you more than life
can we can we have a drink to your
freedom what do you need to kjel I think
you want to drink Cole Swindell Johanna
what can we get you what can we get you
what are you drinking
okay okay like a proper gentleman
tequila tequila are you wearing JW
Marriot slippers oh my Mike what did I
say nothing happens on the carpet for 20
minutes and then everything happens I'm
sweating okay we are live of course is
there any news you want to break are you
pregnant are you pregnant what do you
have to say about the other Lauren B
being pregnant were you confused if
people think it was you I got tagged in
a photo that was okay what are you guys
toasting to tonight here on the morning
toast toast into our our first CMA
together first of many Cheers
you